et alors avant
on dirait que j'ai 5 kg de 10 kg de plus
en plus c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sera fatigué on a pris hier soir que le
joueur serait visé par une enquête pour
viol cette annonce est arrivé seulement
quelques heures après que le joueur a
été nommé parmi les 11 meilleurs joueurs
de l'année par la FIFA qu'est-ce qu'on
s'est de l'histoire il s'est passé il se
serait passé quoi samedi soir au
domicile d'acheter bon écoutez déjà
remettre le contexte est un fait divers
donc on n'a pas énormément
d'informations si ce n'est ce qui est
sorti dans la presse
ce week-end samedi soir à la veille du
classico MPG Ashra fakemi qui ne jouait
pas parce que la petite blessure elle va
plus la Coupe du Monde a reçu aurait
reçu à son domicile une jeune femme de
24 ans qui est issue de Nogent-sur-Marne
donc du 94 donc ça c'est les infos qu'on
a eu et en fait il flirterait ensemble
depuis janvier par Instagram donc une
petite relation épistolaire si on si on
veut dire ça et il aurait fait venir en
taxi chez lui et c'est là que ça aurait
dérapé donc elle a elle a ce soir là
appeler une amie après sa soirée avec
avec le latéral droit du PSG en lui
disant qu'elle avait brusquée etc par le
joueur il aurait forcé à l'embrasser il
aurait pénétrer avec ses doigts donc
d'où la qualification du viol mais ce
qui est un petit peu surprenant et
déroutant de cette affaire c'est qu'elle
n'a pas porté plainte en fait elle a
juste posé une main courante donc ce
qu'il faut savoir là-bas voilà c'est une
grosse différence parce que quand on
peut on met une main la personne qui est
accusée n'est pas forcément au courant
qu'on a voilà qu'on a été le dénoncer
entre guillemets et c'est des sorties
alors que il aurait pas dû le savoir
parce que c'est une star la notoriété
puis la gravités
exactement même si la jeune femme n'a
pas porté plainte le parquet vu
potentiellement la gravité des faits
c'est saisi de la faire c'est le parquet
de Créteil dans le Val-de-Marne ou la
jeune femme est allée qui a transmis à
Nanterre parce que le joueur habite dans
le 92 il habite Boulogne voilà alors il
était seul chez lui sa femme et ses
enfants sont en vacances et il faut dire
aussi qu'aujourd'hui via les médias
espagnols un grand quotidien espagnol
sportif qui s'appelle Marca son
entourage à démenti la jeune femme pour
le moment on n'a pas été entendu une
nouvelle fois par les enquêteurs mais
elle va l'être elle dit qu'elle a envoyé
un SMS à une de ses amis qui est venue
la chercher donc les enquêteurs vont
vérifier la téléphonie savoir ce qui
s'est passé et après on risque d'être
dans un parole contre parole c'est ce
qui peut se passer exactement merci
la plus grande chaîne de fast food
français fait par les d'elle après la
vaisselle dont jetable ils ont décidé de
remplacer les potatoes par des frites de
légumes une décision qui passe pas du
tout chez les fans du grand M moi je
trouve ça bien parce que ça permet aux
gens de découvrir des nouvelles choses
bien sûr que forcément ils iraient pas
vers des frites de légumes il y a des
gens qui trouvent ça très bon et en plus
ça permet d'en manger plus
que la pomme de terre
française des légumes des
Hauts-de-France c'est ça que génial dans
l'initiative
ça va permettre aux jeunes de découvrir
ça franchement c'est formidable il faut
je te fiche mon billet qui a pas un
jeune qui va prendre les délais les
frites carottes c'est génial enfin de la
nourriture saine je le redis si tu vas
dans cet enseigne c'est justement pour
faire un repas un peu transgressif et te
faire plaisir et enfin entre guillemets
et quand tu dis à tes enfants ah bah tu
as bien travaillé machin etc et bah tu
sais quoi pour te faire plaisir on va
aller dans carotte dans cet ensemble
quand on va sur une autoroute on y va
totalement ça fait penser aux gens
parfois tu rencontres quelqu'un pour un
plan sympathique et qui dit je fais que
du soft non quand on fait les choses on
fait les choses
pardon pour l'extrême quand on fait les
jeux si tu veux au McDo tu bouffes MacDo
là il lendemain tu fais attention
[Musique]
tu as fait quoi comme opération toi
parce que là ça se voit pas du tout hein
je retrouve mon visage
alors moi c'est vrai que j'ai fait ma
première télé
j'ai fait les Marseillais et c'est vrai
que de base je n'ai pas de complexe
voilà je n'avais jamais fait de
chirurgie et une fois mon portrait
dévoilé sur les réseaux sociaux
forcément on regarde un petit peu les
commentaires et dans les commentaires
voilà il y avait beaucoup de mauvais
commentaires disant que j'étais moche
que je ressemble à un homme que j'étais
pas belle on faisait des comparaisons
entre les différentes filles dans la
télé etc et c'est vrai que de base
j'avais pas forcément de complexe et en
voyant tous ces commentaires bon tu les
as dans la tête mais bon ça passe et
ensuite
tu te vois donc à la télé je te vois sur
différentes prises de vues que tu devais
pas dans la vie de tous les jours donc
tu vois que ton nez est un petit peu
plus gros
voilà donc là tu te dis bon la prochaine
télé bon je me fais peut-être je me
refais un petit peu le nez pour voir sur
la prochaine télé si ça va mieux à
l'écran non juste j'ai fait de la
médecine esthétique c'est différent de
la chirurgie esthétique médecine
esthétique c'est d'acide hyaluronique
j'ai 5 kg de 10 kg de plus
en fait vu qu'on m'a rajouté de l'acide
hyaluronique forcément je me dis que ça
faisait
bah oui mais là pour le coup en fait
l'arrête de son nez elle est toute fine
là vous avez vu
ton effet il est moins bien là que là
il fait plus long oui exactement mais
c'est même pas ça c'est qu'en fait mes
injonctions ils ont migré et en fait
j'ai des visages bouffis
comment ça se passe pour enlever les
injections on fait comment on fait alors
en fait c'est la technique hyaluronidas
bah tout simplement en fait il faut
c'est un produit naturel pour qui
détruit en fait l'acide hyaluronique ça
fait mal ça fait très très très mal
pour vous donner une idée c'est comme si
on vous en fait déjà quand on vous fait
des injections on vous met du produit là
en fait On vous retire le produit donc
en fait c'est on vous aspire comme si on
vous susurrer le sang quoi
voilà on dit toujours qu'on regarde pas
trop les commentaires etc mais au bout
d'un moment en fait ça rentre dans la
tête au début on regarde pas on calcule
pas le trop mais au bout d'un moment
quand on vous dit oui tu es moche oui ça
oui tu devrais faire si ça ça bah ça
rentre dans la tête et forcément bah tu
le fais et mais moi maintenant oui enfin
la vie le plus important c'est de mes
proches en fait c'est pas de ce qui est
virtuel parce que ça ne veut rien dire
c'était
une copine
en fait au départ je me trouvais mal
merci au début je me trouvais entre
guillemets belle parce que je me disais
les injections ça permet d'embellir donc
mais après en fait j'étais je me rends
compte que j'étais dans le déni et un
jour je me suis réveillé j'ai dit non
mais Laura c'est pas toi même les
anciennes personnes qui me connaissaient
ma mère elle reconnaissait plus elle me
faudra vous arrivez dans la vie
on se disputer parce qu'elle me disait
Laura
est-ce que vous avez porté plainte et
est-ce que vous avez envie que celui qui
vous a fait ça soit sanctionné
j'ai pas pensé à porter plainte
enfin je veux pas me mettre dans des
histoires tout ça mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui ce que je peux dire c'est
que il faut vraiment faire il faut pas
en faire en fait on est belle naturelle
on n'a pas besoin de ça on est jeune au
final comme enfin on revient toujours à
la maison au final j'ai fait tout ça
pour au final
exactement
[Musique]
le juge des libertés de détention a
signé à Résidence Pierre Palmade dans le
service addictologie de l'hôpital Paul
Brousse à Villejuif d'accord ça veut
dire quoi ça donc ça veut dire qu'il ne
pouvait recevoir aucune visite il était
donc il y avait des
il était obligé de rester dans ce
service là et en plus de ça il portait
un bracelet électronique sauf que samedi
il a fait un AVC donc il a il a été
transféré à l'hôpital du où il est sous
surveillance médicale et cette décision
qui a été qui a été faite le 17 février
a été contesté par le parquet et
aujourd'hui ce lundi la cour d'appel de
Paris a ordonné la détention provisoire
de Pierre Palmade et visiblement il a
été écroué il serait rattaché à la
prison de Fred il sera pris en charge
quand il va arriver il verra la
direction le service médical il verra
tous les services qui sont dans la
prison et à l'issue on va l'affecter sur
un bâtiment pour un détenu tout à fait
classique pour lui étant malade
apparemment parce que c'est ce qui se
dit effectivement on peut le mettre à
l'EPSNF à Fresnes et effectivement comme
comme l'a dit et quand tu seras plus
malade guéri ils vont faire quoi ils
sont on peut le transférer dans une
cellule normale des personnalités à la
santé oui oui Balkany mais pareil
c'était seul ou bien ça dépend il y a
certains des fois on est obligé de les
doubler comme par exemple le cas de de
Pierre Palmade effectivement il
paraîtrait qu'il a des envies
suicidaires d'après ce que j'ai entendu
bah lui par exemple on pourra le doubler
pour être sûr qu'il se passe rien dans
la nuit donc parce que bah oui on va
essayer de le mettre avec quelqu'un mais
ça s'apprête c'est la direction qui va
décider il y a quand même un quartier un
peu plus réservé disons aux
personnalités non pas pour qu'ils aient
un statut meilleur oui voilà
et il ne rentre pas en contact avec le
reste de la détention les autres détenus
ne serait-ce que pour les protéger
eux-mêmes on dit le quartier VIP ça veut
pas dire des mesures de faveur ça veut
dire qu'il faut les isoler quelque part
parce que ça peut exciter certains
autres
moi je ne suis pas d'accord
il n'aurait jamais dû se retrouver en
contact avec nous donc il faut
en charge la sécurité et quand vous avez
des personnalités très connues ça peut
mais quand il rentre dans la cellule
vous êtes d'accord qu'il a plus le
téléphone accessible la télé accessible
donc ça sert à quoi de mettre des
quartiers donc tout ce qu'on nous a
raconté dans les médias dans la presse
dans les journaux sur les cellules de
quartier VIP à l'époque où monsieur
balkanietta est tant d'autres politiques
étaient Bernard Tapie et compagnie
toutes les cellules qu'on a vu avec les
grandes télé le grand confort les grands
moelleux confortable à un seul tout ça
c'est du mensonge j'ai inventé je suis
fou alors je sais pas alors peut-être
que moi j'ai envie de mentir ça fait 16
ans que je suis dans la profession et
moi je l'ai jamais vu j'ai jamais vu
dans cette prison mais dans les prisons
n'existe pas aujourd'hui est-ce que tu
es encore en contact avec lui non
d'accord mais c'est vrai que ton regard
c'est que tu as réagi comment on apprend
j'étais là
le premier jour de où il a commencé sur
scène et je l'ai emmené du Point Virgule
un an après au Palais des Glaces un an
après trois semaines fermées à l'Olympia
18 19 20 ans
aujourd'hui toi tu penses que c'était
c'était inévitable ce qui s'est arrivé
un drame ou pas l'accident
toujours pensé que ça arriverait un jour
quand tu prends des quantités pareilles
il y a un moment
toi tu as déjà eu des
soirées comme ça et dis-nous la vérité
à cause de la cocaïne sa vie elle est
brisée
[Musique]
de la banlieue parisienne problème
d'hygiène et de décongélation des
aliments présence d'insectes équipement
sales dont réconcés dans des conditions
inadéquates face au nombreuses
infractions constatées la préfecture du
Val-d'Oise a décidé de fermer
l'établissement jusqu'à nouvel an alors
ce que les agences sanitaires ont trouvé
dans la franchise chicken Street à
garage les gonesse donc il y avait donc
de la viande décongelé qui est baigné
dans une eau stagnante
ça c'est chaud ça c'est chaud ça c'est
chaud il y avait de la sauce avec des
traces de moisissures regardez
il y a des steaks hachés conserver une
température bien trop élevée regardez
55 degrés ils ont détecté un danger
grave et imminent pour la santé et il
faut avouer que l'affirme a tout de
suite réagi Cyril et ça c'est bien parce
que sinon ça risque c'est ce que vous
disiez franchement c'est une firme
dynamique qui bosse avec plein
d'associations notamment en
Île-de-France ils 50 restaurants ils ont
11 ans d'existence et ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent et ce restaurant avait été
contrôlé par eux par l'extérieur et ils
ont fait un peu ils ont non excusez-moi
ils ont fait un communiqué tout de suite
pour dire qu'ils vont se séparer de se
franchiser ils portent plainte c'est
bien c'est bien
non j'allais pas faire fermer on fait
passer plein d'emploi Valérie et alors
on ne sait pas ce qu'on fait quand on
donne à manger notamment à des enfants
rappelle-toi buttoni rappelle-toi des
enfants qui en sont morts d'autres qui
sont dans des états pas possible et pour
et à vie donc excuse-moi fais pas ce
qu'on peut dire que la marque a bien
réagiaire
quand on est franchisé on se doit
respecter une certaine charte bien
entendu des règles mais bien entendu
quand même pas à vous il est pas à vous
et donc on sait très bien que quand on a
pas indépendant les gens malheureusement
respectent pas les règles et s'il y a
des condamnations dans ces cas-là qui
prend c'est la marque ou le franchisé
responsable pénalement puisque c'est
elle qui met la nourriture
à disposition du grand public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]